[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week boy we have some great things
that we're going to do today but the one
thing i want to do there's even there
there is even uh
one of the candidates
there has been an update in the last
three minutes oh has there really so
you're keeping an eye on the news yeah
in the news um well let's let's go to
the candidates here and let's not waste
a lot of time we have the governor greg
abbott
elon musk and charlie kirk um obviously
there's a lot of
fanfare i guess you'd say i don't know i
don't know i guess maybe that you'd say
over some of these elon musk just can't
stop uh we can't stop talking about this
[ __ ] he bought nine percent of the
company uh of twitter then he wants to
buy twitter mark cuban this morning is
claiming he's doing a pump and dump
which is my belief did he say i thought
he said that yesterday the day before he
but yes essentially he he um he's saying
he's driving up the price he's driving
yeah he's driving same thing he did with
tesla and all trying to do it before the
sec is like wait what the [ __ ] going
on you know right right exactly well and
and i mean
honestly i said this yesterday
the fact that the fact that elon musk
was like take it or leave it is it's not
a serious thing like when you're talking
about right 43 billion dollars a take it
a lever take it or leave it offer is not
going to be viewed seriously in any
boardroom across right well i mean
here's the thing the things that i've
seen on the right they're like oh okay
again let's go back to the group of
people on the right who say i'm getting
off twitter because it's suppressing my
my voice it's silencing me uh i need to
have my freedom of speech and they're
restricting my my my first amendment
right which is none of that is true okay
uh you could say dumb [ __ ] you could say
stupid [ __ ] you could say a bunch of
rather just terrible dumb takes right uh
you could be bigoted whatever now you
can say those things it doesn't remove
any sort of consequence from the action
that you took right so if that is in
regards to your job employer employees
friends family whatever they push you
aside and say
we don't want to be affiliated with you
that's not twitter's fault that is your
fault you did that you did that to
yourself you dragged yourself through
the mud and the [ __ ] and everything and
then now that you're all a mess you're
like wait wait this is not fair what's
going on you did it you did it to
yourself okay just understand it there
there are consequences to the actions
you take okay it's consequence culture
it's not cancer culture
now these people on the right
who claim these things and i'm going to
gab and i'm going to get her and i'm
going to choose social i'm going to
parlor and i'm going to rumble and i'm
going to whatever the other [ __ ] dumb
websites that they go to where they say
that the the freedom of speech is
unrestricted and we can do whatever they
want who rob we can be as racist and
terrible
here's the thing
those people
100 of the time
are on twitter stay on twitter despite
the fact that they go there's gonna be a
mass exodus they set it for all of these
different apps right all of the
different apps and what it ends up being
they come back to
[ __ ] on twitter on twitter because they
can't get away they want twitter so
badly despite the fact that they're
saying they're gonna leave in a mass
exodus and they're gonna go to these
these right-wing first amendment
prohibits because they need it it's
because they need it right they need it
i mean i mean look at marjory taylor
green she's a perfect case study she
loses her personal account but she's
still and she goes out and she's like i
was banned from twitter like she wears
it as a badge and she's still tweeting
on her her [ __ ] congressional account
yeah like she speaks every [ __ ] day
on her congressional account exactly so
she didn't leave twitter and she didn't
get kicked off twitter i mean she
probably should be there's a good case
that she should be but it's her
congressional account and she knew that
paul goes are the same way he would
cheat tweet crazy [ __ ] from his
congressional account because he well
from his congressional because he knew
that they wouldn't [ __ ] ban right
right so which is which is uh you know
obviously
is you know i i don't know there's a lot
of like uh what's allowed and you know
in terms of like a government official
and things of that like i i think there
should be some sort of like hey this
tweet is [ __ ] uh homophobic well i
mean i mean transphobic right you know
like margie taylor green had video last
like two weeks that was i was pushing
transphobic messaging and uh and twitter
was like this is fine well i don't i
don't think i don't think twitter has
the permaban no no no no an official
account like like a representative i
think they can just they can they can
hide tweets if they need to hide them if
they're and you know what
you know what they could do as well is
they could just suspend them from having
any uh any activity to where it's just
like an archive like they can't right
tweet they can't post you can just read
it right you can just read the archive
right so speaking speaking of um
people who were who have been suspended
from twitter charlie kirk is also on the
list i don't want to spend a lot of time
on this guy because i really want to
move forward to greg abbott and our
dishonorable mention today um
but charlie kirk he said tall buildings
are liberal is that is that kind of you
he
he's like oh the taller the building the
more liberal it is
i believe what he was saying is he was
saying black people live in tall
buildings and that's why tall buildings
are bad white people live in nice
suburban houses with big yards and
that's why they're good that's what i
thought yeah i mean yes he could very
well make the case of like uh oh you're
in a city and certain demographic is
stacked on each other in buildings and
whatnot i mean like his also his other
argument was like if you're conservative
you're out in the land your hands are
you're you're sowing the seeds and
you're working the
this is okay
hold on where did charlie kirk grow up
let's look at this ready
let's look at this i would imagine he
grew up with the dirt under his
fingernails i mean and he grew up in
arlington heights illinois which is a
suburb of chicago oh really do you know
where arlington heights illinois is yeah
yeah
yeah it's over by valentine it's it's
like a little south uh you're you're
saying it's like a rural farming where
they actually grow food and the only
food they eat is the food
no no no
no no no no no it's uh so it there's
chicago and then it's it's uh it's right
it's a suburb right yeah northwest yeah
yeah so it's over by like you know
schaumburg and schaumburg
palentine hoffman estates like all these
places are cookie cutter homes they're
all like
uh you go
you mean you mean big houses with nice
big yards with a lot of white yeah you
know a lot of cul-de-sacs a lot of
cul-de-sacs right they don't want people
coming in again right people know
anything about cul-de-sac history on
them uh but
that's the type of town that he grew up
in and also if you look at those the
town that i grew up in like the highest
building you're going to have commercial
buildings there i mean they're not going
to be skyscrapers but they're going to
be 20 30
like floors right
so for this guy also uh a big fan of
trump and i'm pretty sure he said trump
built tremendous or magnificent
buildings right so well we went through
this yesterday and really honestly he's
like trump i i said this yesterday like
if charlie kirk would have left the
podium and donald trump came up right
after him he would be like i build the
tallest best buildings ever they're mo
the glorious department's the best right
most fantastic i mean he would brag
about how tall his buildings are right
yeah and they and the people in the
crowd would clap yeah
for how buildings are liberal but the
thing is and the reason why here's why i
said this yesterday the reason why those
people clap so hard in the audience and
they would clap for trump is because
they knew what charlie was saying
charlie was saying we want more white
neighborhoods with nice suburbia white
neighborhoods with less with less people
of color right in them and we want the
people of color to be in the big tall
high-rises quote-unquote ghettos because
that's that's what they were clapping
right i mean you remember trump during
the during the campaign was saying like
oh they're gonna ruin no whoever you
know they are will just use it very
loosely as anyone who's not white is
going to ruin the suburbs right you know
the cory bookers trump said mm-hmm uh
yeah those black dudes right right like
you know his he couldn't be more more
right the dog whistle was pretty clear
that was there right uh but yeah it's
the same type of stuff like trump saying
like oh suburbs would be ruined because
they're gonna be like no no that's not
how it goes or suburban housewife he
would say suburban house life like yeah
do you realize that most of suburbia
they're not housewives they work because
they have to afford to live there right
what are you [ __ ] talking about
there's not that many households in this
country anymore with one income they're
just not right it's not a thing that
exists as much speaking of households
and married couples and you know rather
they get along or
they arouse each other um our our alpha
guck of the week is ben shapiro
like that photo i found oh my god that's
fantastic it actually looks like it
actually looks like him having the
conversation with his wife about what a
whop is and what a dap is right so
you're telling me um
it's not supposed to be dry
oh my god so as everyone knows um and if
you if you want you can go to our
youtube channel please subscribe to the
youtube channel
uh we put up a video of me and gabe
breaking down uh ben shapiro and why he
was punked basically by a student
um should we play this video one more
time
give context because here's the thing
even even if they already know the
context the video's still funny right
it's well and it's like what it's like
11 seconds long yeah i mean this is this
is like listen it's probably longer than
shapiro in bed
[Music]
oh okay so let's let's play the video
here this is what happened he was at
some kind of a fascist talking thing
event and uh a student got handed the
microphone and listened to what the
student says uh be be very very clear on
what the student says we'll play it once
which i literally use throughout the
speech not generally you sound like a
bozo bro
you get no [ __ ] and you can't even make
your wife wet bro so what's good
i mean i think everything i think we
should have renamed this one to bozo of
the week bozo of the week that goes over
the week but the reason why he's the
alpha cuckoo of the week is not
necessarily
not necessarily why he got alpha cuck of
the week here because he did get kind of
get cucked here but the reason why is
because
ben shapiro kind of told on himself a
couple years ago when he was totally
offended totally offended by cardi b
song
[ __ ] which stands for wet ass [ __ ] for
those who don't know um because that's
important because he claimed that there
is no such thing as a wet ass [ __ ] that
cardi b was uh operating in fiction
because his wife has told him that that
doesn't exist um that she doesn't get
uh aroused like that and her vagina does
not do that thing and he kind of told on
himself that right he dries up the room
when he walks in what do you what did
you think i said ben shapiro sucks the
moisture out of the room right when he
walks in right right like ben shapiro
everyone just like is like so
like
bone and just like leather skin
[Laughter]
so that's why that's why ben shapiro is
the alpha cook of the week so like
congratulations to ben shapiro on on
gaming this is the first time by the way
this is the first time he's been on the
show really actually on bone end of the
week
congratulations to ben give him a round
of applause
oh yeah that's fantastic so if you guys
want to go watch that clip um go to our
youtube channel and you'll find the ben
shapiro uh clip of me and uh gabe
talking about uh
[ __ ] and wet ass [ __ ] it's fantastic
and and you get to see gabe's
impersonation of uh ben shapiro which is
also fantastic um but this moves me to
our dishonorable mention which i really
want to focus on our bone of the week
winner uh we'll give him his due but i
really want to focus on this story
because this is the story of the day uh
mark meadows is this the one that you're
saying there's some updates in the land
no no no the one that i'm referring to
is elon musk oh okay so yeah let's let's
move let's go to that verse let's give
us the elon musk news here and then
we'll go to uh mark meadows chip roy
and um uh
senator mike lee all sexting each other
seditiously sexting so what's the elon
musk news so they responded i just saw
that uh
that twitter twitter responded twitter
responded and
um
yeah it's just like
okay so basically uh the the ap news
article says twitter adopts a poison
pill defense in musk takeover bid
uh twitter said friday that its board of
directors has unanimously adopted a
poison pill defense in response to a
tesla ceo elon musk's proposal to buy
the company to take a private they said
the move formally called a limited
duration shareholder rights plan aims to
enable its investors to realize the full
value of their investment by reducing
the likelihood that any one person can
gain control of the company without
either paying shareholders a premium or
giving the board more time poison pills
are often used as defense against
hostile takeovers which happens all time
at companies where some person you know
gets up majority and then or has the
majority stake within the company and
then tries to push out people or or
assign a new board of directors or
executives
under their own kind of direction and
says twitter's plan would take effect if
musk's roughly nine percent stake gross
to 15 or more even then musk could still
take over the company with a proxy vote
by voting uh out the current directors
twitter said the plan doesn't prevent
the board from engaging with parties or
accepting an acquisition proposal if
it's in the company's best interest
twitter had revealed that his security
filings thursday that musk offered by
the company outright for more than 43
billion saying that social media
platform needs to be transformed as a
private company in order to build trust
with its users i i don't know if that's
necessarily true you know but that's
musk's idea and it goes and then he's
saying [ __ ] about i believe in free
speech there is free speech on twitter
you [ __ ] right yeah right well i mean
here's the thing is really honestly uh
twitter's free speech only your free
speech on twitter only extends to how
much uh twitter is willing to let you do
that right exactly you could you could
say ridiculous you you you could post
the most insane
vile disgusting bigoted
homophobic transphobic racist uh
whatever you wanted to post as long as
they'll leave it there it's yeah now
here's the thing now whether or not
other people look at that and say this
is [ __ ] up and then report you and
then twitter says ah yeah that's pretty
messed up it violates
our private companies
terms of service
that you agree to you click the little
boxes i agree with the privacy policy
the terms of service yes i want to
create an account there's community
guidelines to make sure that doesn't
just [ __ ] go into the craziness
so if other people report you or there's
some sort of uh
you know like moderation aspect of it
that's on you because you posted
something that that was against the
thing that you agreed to right right so
don't worry
don't get mad at other people if you
want to post that racist [ __ ] if you
really want to post that racist [ __ ] on
the internet
go start your own website you can post
it on there yeah you can you can post it
on i i hate freespeech.com or whatever
you want go buy go buy you a [ __ ]
website over at godaddy and you can just
start posting and posting posting you
don't have the right to [ __ ] for
everyone to see your racism just because
you want them to on twitter's website
that's not how it works uh thank you to
mj she gave us a super chat here for
the no wet ass [ __ ] bozo she said hey
and then uh tony tony thank you for the
super chat and we have gaby here with
the super sticker thank you away baby
for the super chat the super stickers
here on bonehead of the week if you want
to get in on the super chat go subscribe
to the youtube channel you can do
super chat
subscribe um during the show
um so the the remaining part here so
there was a video that was yesterday uh
later on thursday during a non-stage
interview at ted 2022 conference he went
on musk went on even broader having a
public platform that is maximally
trusted and broadly inclusive is
extremely important to the future
civilization
musk revealed in a regulatory filings
over recent weeks that he'd been buying
twitter shares in almost daily batches
starting january 31st like so this is
not again for people this guy this is
just like outright buy nine percent he
was strategically buying stuff little in
little like breadcrumb increments right
to get himself to a point because you
know where he can see now the poison
building you're saying what facebook is
doing it sounds like what they're doing
is making sure that a billionaire can't
yeah excuse me yeah twitter is making
sure that a billionaire can't just come
in and destroy their company right
they're putting in a condition to say
like oh if he gets over this percentage
then you know
then this you know poison pill goes into
effect but that's the defense that
they're making right now which is like
they want to prevent anyone because they
see they see what he wants to he wants
to
him yeah yeah he's not wanting to save
twitter he's wanting to destroy it right
right and so you know if it's like he
really wanted to create something
himself i mean here's here's the other
thing like obviously like elon musk has
created companies but everyone's like oh
tesla tesla he didn't start tesla he
came in as an investor and then took it
over when he realized that people the
original two co-founders uh after it
started gaining popularity they weren't
talking about they weren't mentioning
him because it was he was just an
investor he wasn't the one behind the
ideas right a pistol and he got and then
he you know took him he pushed him out
and well
man i get this all the time when i knock
on elon musk on a clip or some [ __ ]
they're like oh
he invented the electric car i'm like
[ __ ] this is a guy who's got a
silver spoon from blood diamonds in
south africa
and and and yes is he smart is he does
he know market sure whatever he he might
know but but you [ __ ] in-cell people
out there who thinks he's some kind of
[ __ ] self-made brainiac genius you
are full of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he's not
self-made he is not a genius i can tell
you i know i have friends who have
worked
at tesla i have a another friend who is
a literal rocket scientist
wait wait wait wait wait an actual one
not like an actual one like an actual
rocket scientist right at spacex and
i've heard stories from both of them
where they have told me that
here's the thing
elon is good at absorbing like snippets
of of not like info right he can he can
learn about something and discuss it to
an extent however
he's not a genius he's not my god
you're blowing our minds that he's not a
rocket scientist sorry i really i really
thought i really thought when he rode
when he gets his space dildo in the
space i really thought that that meant
that he was the actual one like tony
starking it like he's building it in his
basement and yeah everyone wants to be
iron man but he is not iron man i know
it's so disappointing it's so
disappointing speaking of just go ahead
go ahead so the last thing is after musk
announced his stake twitter quickly
offered him a seat on the board of the
condition that he would be limit his
purchase doing no more than 14.9 percent
of the company's outstanding stock but
the company said five days later that
must have declined so this is when he
initially uh was given a board seat
right because he doesn't actually want
to do work he doesn't want to yeah he
doesn't want to do this [ __ ] he wanted
to get in there and make the changes he
want whatever it might be they know he
wants to destroy twitter they know it
they know exactly the writing's on the
wall
well let's move to let's move to the
story of the day
i'm here to mark meadows oh kelly thank
you for the superhero thank you for the
super sticker kelly let's move to the um
to the uh story of the day which is we
dishonorable mention here is mark
meadows and it really seems like mark
meadows phone
was completely open and i don't know if
he was like advertising it out there on
like
on like dating websites or something but
he was receiving a ton
a ton of
sex messaging oh yeah i mean it wasn't
just it wasn't just don jr or
i mean these people he had a whole slew
from uh of trumpers that were really
really really into tearing down when you
say trumpers let's clarify these are
people
close within the circle
or uh within the the trump um uh
kind of network either representative
senators or those within the actual
white house so that's something that uh
that people need to know here is like
it's not just like oh it was texting
with something like trump supporter it
was like no these are people with actual
like voting power right and have actual
influence in politics which is
so who are who are these people because
i want to bring this i'm going to bring
this up here
so remember today we have two people in
the news other than mark meadows right
so the original remember the original
text that came out during the january
6th committee um was
sean hannity laura ingraham
uh don jr
and
um
what's his face from uh
from
um from batman no i meant the joker is
that who was no no i mean who knows uh
though i think the joke would be like uh
dude not my style
right
so
so oh the other one was uh what's his
face from the um
fox and friends yeah i forget his name
yes so those are the original it was
like why why is mark meadows why does
mark meadows have a direct line into
these
uh entertainment correspondence let's
call it what it is not news
correspondents entertainment
correspondents
then
texts get announced that uh there are
ones between mark meadows and jenny
thomas and you're like whoa whoa jenny
thomas that's the wife of supreme court
justice clarence thomas
what is going on here we already know
that well and not to mention
not to mention she's texting him queuing
on stuff like this just wasn't like
right this wasn't just let's overturn
the election like she was down deep
inside the the q anon base like she was
writing facebook and just regurgitating
that she went on she was deep in that
hole that sounds so good which which
really which really these texts that
we're seeing today are kind of different
from that right they're not
government of the united states like
right he's really he's not using
conspiracy theories as much he actually
is knocking conspiracy theorists like
sydney powell saying oh this is this is
bad if we want to overturn this election
sydney powell and q anon is really awful
if we want to make sure we subvert the
constitution here right like he's making
that case to mark meadows so mark
meadows just wasn't receiving the q anon
theory right he was receiving rebuttals
like hey if you want to overthrow the
government right we need to stop playing
around with these q a like right right
just the fact that that it wasn't just
like hey man
like let's let's just let the process
work itself out let's not try to
uh uh cause some sort of like
block or or try to um
to to prevent it from happening you know
it really was like yeah let's let's try
to stop this [ __ ] right uh because
that's what was happening and here's one
here it says from mike lee to mark
meadows these are from cnn.com these are
the text messages i'm sure gabe will be
doing a uh another text messages from i
just did one with don junior that was
another one that came out where don
junior was like we've got control we own
the states right trump's going to do
whatever we want and that was before
january 6th and before and after the
election too right so here's from mike
lee to mark meadows we're sending this
as a private communication from us to
him through you we are not issuing it as
a press release um and then also use it
however you deem appropriate like
however you want to overthrow the
constitution just do that
you know and it and here's it goes on
and if it's helpful to you for you to
leak it feel free to do so
question mark mark brenda's like what
wait a second what you want me to leak
my text messages this information um and
here's where he kind of starts knocking
on sydney powell cindy powell is saying
that she needs to get in to see the
president but she's being kept away from
him apparently she has a strategy to
keep things alive but several states pay
are back in play can you help get her in
so this is where he's kind of on her
side right later on after she does the
press conference let me find that spot
the press conference where rudy
giuliani's hair starts leaking yes and
sydney pal starts talking craziness
right and that's that's that is when
everyone went [ __ ] crazy for the
kraken right uh the kraken is the
biggest flop in human history right
because that's what she was talking
about voting machines and hugo chavez
and who had been built yeah yeah that
was great that was right so this is
november uh 19th after this press
conference um and this is from lee to
meadows i'm worried about the pal chris
so he was for her talking to the
president yeah yeah now he's like oh my
god she's a [ __ ] crazy is this after
when was that conference was that after
november i'm not real sure but he says
i'm worried well you might check that
i'm worried about this press conference
um mike lee says potential defamation
liability for president is significant
here um and that's because she was
making pressing comments about dominion
and stuff that we're not [ __ ] true
and now we see a defamation suit against
her and rudy giuliani and mike lindell
and others but mike lee says for the
campaign and for the president
personally saying that this is
significant and it's going to damage the
campaign and the president personally
in other words mike lee seen this as a
threat um to their you know reputation
so going back to november 19th he
watched that press conference and then
sent that text as it was happening oh so
so it this he's texting this to mark
meadows the press conference was on
november 19th which means he started
watching he was like oh [ __ ] is off the
rails
and we don't have time stamps here so it
may be right there or right out right
yeah yeah because here's what's
happening they're making all these
claims
and then obviously uh you know this is
all there it's still the 19th of
november yeah all this is the 90s yeah
yeah okay yeah so you know i'm sure
well i mean here and here here in here
here mike lee says unless powell can
immediately substantiate what she said
today the president should probably
disassociate himself which he then did
that's right so they were listening to
mike lee here which this is kind of
crazy and the reason why it's kind of
crazy that they're listening to mike lee
is because there was something else
significant that i want to point out to
you that is absolutely batshit crazy and
this is the reason why um here's one um
about john eastman uh but i want to move
to another one but uh why we're here
john eastman has really interesting
research on this the good news is
is that eastman is proposing an approach
that unlike sydney powell has
proposed could be examined very quickly
in other words he's promoting the cheeto
dust kangaroo plan the john eastman is
still doing that [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah well which uh he'll probably end up
in federal prison for yeah for several
years um let's see the one thing i
wanted to show though that i found in
these text messages which scared the
absolute [ __ ] bejesus out of me um i
was like holy actual [ __ ]
is that they were they were crowd
sourcing we know the president united
states donald trump at the time right
was listening to fox news right
but here is a united states senator let
me see if i can no text on on january 6
which is very interesting right right
right um but
that's 20 that's 20 20. right right
these are 20 20. the um
he was listening to mark levin and he's
telling mark meadows to go watch mark
levin's show on fox news because mark
levin lays it out on fox news
how we can overturn the cons
constitution of the united states it is
some weird ass [ __ ] to see a text
message from a sitting senator in the
united states who you think well they're
probably pretty smart right
texting the chief of staff who stands
for november 23rd 2020 is that one if
you haven't watched tonight's episode of
life liberty 11 then that's it that's it
yeah that's it
yeah the 23rd yeah it was right there
above the ishmael one yeah if you
haven't watched yet watched tonight's
episode of life liberty and levin that's
mark levin yeah [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
show on
on fox news you should do so if you can
fit it in levin makes a very compelling
case for the need to litigate
litigation related to this election so
like literally they're saying out loud
go listen to fox news fox news has the
road map right they're
broadcasting yeah like this is absolute
batshit bonkers crazy folks
when you are in government and you are
serious about policy and you are serious
about what you're doing in government
you don't go watch a youtube video that
has q and on conspiracy theories right
you do not go watch a cable news station
like joe biden to figure out what
litigation he needs to have doesn't go
watch rachel maddow's show i would
seriously [ __ ] doubt if joe biden
even watches rachel maddow yeah i would
seriously doubt that he watches jake
tapper if if you
if you are in a uh political position
you're the president of the united
states let's say or you're just uh you
know
you're uh a us representative or senator
um
and you are saying hey you should go
listen to cause it's not oh let's just
call it's not fox news you know it's
faux news it's
fox news it's
not really news it's an entertainment
it's [ __ ] news
uh but in in that situation
if you are relying
on the opinion
of a person on a show who may have had
someone do some research and maybe
there's to some extent some truth to a
path forward doesn't mean that it's
actually a path it just means like oh
there might be a case to actually
present forward but it won't really hold
any ground you know the fact that you
would say oh the president should ignore
uh his legal team or or the people
working for him and you know what they
didn't even think of this thing let's go
over to mark levin and listen to this
guy's show because he's got the answer
well if anyone doesn't know who mark
levin is because it's important to uh
point this out he is a right-wing talk
radio show host
that's what he is he is like a rush
limbaugh
and he was given a fox news show because
he's a [ __ ] fascist
and this guy was vehemently anti-trump
when trump wasn't the nominee in 2016. i
listened to mark levin a lot i used to
listen to wrestling ball sean hannity i
deemingly disagree with them and i
diametrically opposed almost everything
they believe but i listened to them
because i wanted to know what they were
saying because that's where these people
were hearing it and mark levin was
anti-trump because trump is a buffoon
and [ __ ] mark levin hated that about
trump that he's a [ __ ] buffoon now
he's a trump sycophant right because the
the tail is wagging the dog in this
country on the right wing yeah that's
what is happening the fascists have
taken over the party and they've taken
it over
um did you want to say something about
chip roy because they're the chip roy
also
right so chip chip roy is also one of uh
one of these people that threw
themselves in the text uh and
you know texting
mark meadows to again figure out you
know he's got stuff that's like we have
no tools dead information to go out and
fight for the election fraud if you know
if you need wanna we all need to know
what's going on for what it's worth so
he's like
not part of the conversation
uh again
has no
has no position to be in to to involve
himself
but is now trying to be like oh how do i
kiss this ass right how do i how do i
[ __ ] uh uh get get trump's attention
so that he knows that i am a loyal loyal
servant to him you know
and uh
you know then there's like oh mark
meadows and chip roy thanks so much
working on it for the surrogates
briefing congratulations by the way goes
yes sir now let's hold uh georgia and
take arizona and pennsylvania like
they're all talking about this stuff you
know behind the scenes
and
well they're even talking about how
they're on the phone with state
legislators day in and day out to try to
overturn this election exactly like
chip roy comes in no more than a kiss
ass he's just brown-nosing at this point
in my opinion he put himself in the
situation or in the discussion with mark
meadows so that when you know push comes
to shove at the end of the day if trump
does come through he looks at all the
loyalists that were with him during that
time and says you stay you stay you stay
you stay and by that i mean like
my word trump's word which is means [ __ ]
in terms of like what he promises
i think that is that is trump's attempt
to say like oh those who are loyal to me
will have my undying support and uh and
admiration right uh which we've seen go
to the wayside with people like uh mo
brooks right who was very much for
january 6 pushing and fighting uh and
and disagreeing with the certification
and then now that he recently was like
oh i actually told trump not to do i
think he i think he got interviewed by
federal prosecutors right and they're
like listen this is what you're actually
looking at and before i think a lot of
these people also are are under the
the guys or the the kind of uh idea that
they're not going to be in any way held
liable for what was said or done
and the federal prosecutors come in
they're like listen so we got uh
communication on this this this this you
were here on these dates you said these
things we can connect you to these
people whether you were directly
involved you were indirectly involved
because of some sort of
something you did and they're like so
these are the charges realistic that we
can bring against you and then
uh he's like uh
okay okay okay um so what i really meant
to say was
uh you know and then goes in and then
you know speaks out now these people
have to be publicly against trump and
anything he was trying to do for january
6 and now trump says oh those [ __ ]
rat [ __ ] and then comes after them to
say that oh i don't trust them i endorse
the opposing candidate if they're in a
re-election campaign uh it's like you
know again
just like comey said like you're he's
always asking for loyalty and if you're
not proving to be loyal to him then he
will cut you
as soon as he can right and
yeah and i'll tell you that
speaking of uh sycophants trying to
placate to trump uh our bonehead of the
week is one of those um the winner of
our bonehead of the week is governor
greg abbott and boy is he really is he
really uh sucking at the teeth of the
trump supporters here he goes to events
and says uh god hail trump and they're
like booing him and [ __ ] but um i got a
video here that i want to show that was
posted by his opponent um well maybe his
opponent
in the uh texas race for governor beto
o'rourke and this is a a line of trucks
let me mute it here this is the line of
trucks that's waiting um to be inspected
by the highway patrol they're going to
check the tire pressure on these trucks
because they can't check the cargo uh as
everyone knows governor greg abbott is
really trying to make sure that your
grocery store shelves are empty he's old
empty shelves abbott
and the reason why is because he wants
to try to step up the supply chain on
purpose so that way it gets blamed on
joe biden so when you go vote you'll
blame joe biden you'll blame beto
o'rourke and you'll vote for him so he's
using his power as governor to get to
texas what is essentially the higher
patrol in texas to stop up the supply
chain at our border where we get a lot
of food right a lot of electronics a lot
of vehicles that is manufactured grown
and brought here from mexico um and
which our country relies on for those
shelves that you complain about being
empty yeah you know like tiffany's that
you know there's no right right it's
almost you know i look at this and i'm
like wow this is a pretty effective
truck convoy right almost feel like greg
abbott should have been the one behind
planning the truck convoy to actually
stop them that is true that is true
because you look at this and it's like
you've got wow
tons of freight containers and and
trailers on these trucks
spoiling right well you know the other
thing too is these truckers aren't
interested in being in a convoy they
want to move their wheels right and they
want to go to their destination now i
also don't know the situation here in
terms of like if anyone out there knows
anything about like
being a trucker or the trucking industry
what happens in this scenario you you
literally cannot move you're just
sitting the truck so are these people
getting paid plus overtime
from the trucking companies because that
like they're stacked they're technically
like they they cannot prevent it they're
they're late and and uh overdue on
delivery because
of a uh you know federal bureaucracy and
and uh abbott trying to
do something that's completely idiotic
but when i look at that i say like oh
well these truckers they can't they have
no control they cannot go through
they're being stopped
so are they getting paid are they not
getting paid you know uh like maybe
they're getting paid like the wheels if
the wheels aren't moving they're not
getting paid most truckers in this
country get paid per mile right so so
that's why that's why when you see a
truck why are the why is this like this
[ __ ] like if there was ever a truck or
convoy to like go against anything why
wouldn't it be this right like i look at
the situation i say this is this is
complete [ __ ] where a governor is
using his power to
to play around with uh withholding
supply chain going into the country
and the truckers are just like well i
guess i'll just sit in my truck like
what are they doing right like i don't
know why there's not some sort of like
protest to this well you know i'll tell
you that a lot of the trucking industry
in this country
unbeknownst to a lot of people most of
the truck drivers very high percentage
of the truck drivers in this country uh
rather people like it or know it or not
a lot a lot of them are rural people
right but a big high percentage of truck
drivers in this country are are
immigrants they're immigrants um and the
reason why is because it is a
you do you have to have a high skill in
truck driving but it does not require a
lot of money a lot of resources to drive
for a big trucking company and you can
generally make a very good income in
this country uh driving a truck because
you get to drive so many miles now
there's different regulations like
between this point and that point and
this but you generally get a very good
income for your household by driving a
truck which you have to have a high
skill
but you don't have to have a lot of
money in education and and background
and experience you just have to have the
skill of driving so uh margie said here
uh she's like hey tony he changed it so
now he is having the mexican government
do it so he can't be blamed
right well i mean i mean he's still
doing it so we're still going to blame
it yeah yeah we're still going to blame
it i mean obviously like it will come
down to semantics because like well i'm
not doing it right they are actually
inspect right now it's at the request of
greg abbott so now he's using
uh
mexico's taxpayer money right here's
what i'll tell you marge here's what
i'll tell you margie if if if there's
not a better sign that greg abbott knows
he's going to be blamed for this and
he's not and he's not getting the blame
pushed on the right person it's because
better o'rourke is actually doing his
job and ruining the campaign against him
but here's the thing is him pushing it
to the mexican government only tells me
that he knows it's very [ __ ]
unpopular and it's not a popular thing
to do and he will get blamed for it and
he doesn't want to be blamed for it
which is why we should blame him for it
and keep pressing him um so let's do
this let's give greg abbott his due of
the week we are over time but let's give
greg abbott's due the week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] greg abbott yeah [ __ ] him [ __ ]
because i also want to point out one
other thing that really pisses me off um
the guy straight up kidnapped in traffic
people and sent them to dc right many of
them are saying one some of them aren't
even illegal right they're not like
that's one thing that's uh that i was
thinking about the other day where i was
like oh you know god forbid somebody is
just assumed to be illegal or not a
resident of the us because of how they
look right
i have a draft in my tweets that i did
not even send out but i was like oh
i guarantee that there's probably going
to be some people that come forward or
reveal that greg abbott just goes you
look brown you look
you're
mexican you're out right you're out but the
other thing is there were reports of
people saying that they were going to
florida
right they're going to be deported to
florida outside of texas but really what
ends up happening is they get pumped up
and shipped out to to new york or to dc
and uh uh
they were just openly admitting like oh
yeah we took people against their will
we put them to a place that uh that they
didn't agree to or they weren't aware of
we trafficked people you know across
state lines we kidnapped them against
their uh against their their will you
know and then obviously people on the
right are gonna be like oh well they're
illegal or they're not residents they
don't have god they don't have god given
right yeah yeah they don't have
god-given rights it's this is all
ridiculous and they're you know i talked
about this earlier in the show on the
statistic that there's five million more
jobs than we have unemployed people in
this country and the reason why and
rachel pointed out very clearly that we
we so have demonized migrants and
immigrants in this country migrants and
immigrants in this country play such a
vital role into getting food on our
[ __ ] tables that people do not
understand it and it is very important
that we fill a lot of those positions so
when you go to your restaurant when you
go and you see shortages where they're
they're having to close down early or
they can't
guys it's because because the republican
party is demonizing immigration they're
demonizing immigrants they're demonizing
migrants to come to our country and to
work here they are part of our workforce
whether you [ __ ] like it or not they
are part of our workforce they're vital
to our country whether they're legal or
illegal whatever the hell you want to
say they are vital to our economy and
they're vital to our country so great
point on that um [ __ ] greg abbott [ __ ]
him
because as the as the as the the son of
an immigrant to this country i'm
mexican-american
and
this [ __ ]
is
is is disgusting and the fact that it
was kind of like well whatever you know
you know they pushed him up there and
was some political move in terms of for
greg abbott to like make a point that
it's joe biden's border problem
well you know the fact that brit is okay
and there's seems to be no repercussions
for the fact that greg abbott is just
trafficking people or or kidnapping them
against their will and what they were
told they were going to go
where they were going to go versus where
they actually went is insane
and of course the group on the right you
know gqp right-wing extremists whatever
you want to call them look at that and
they go yeah well
they had it coming like what the [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] well so they're they're
they're brown so who cares right i mean
that's that's that's really what it is
right and it's racism is what it is
let's just call it the way it is so [ __ ]
greg abbott [ __ ] him and i'm glad he's
the bone of the week thank you remember
go to at tony michael's pod to vote
every single week and bone of the week
and then every friday in the second hour
of the tony michaels broadcast me and
gabe break down your vote your vote for
bonehead of the week thanks for joining
us stick around we'll be right back
after the song
[Music]
[Applause]